heute wurde bekannt dass estée lauder
der große amerikanische
kosmetikkonzern auch seinen verkauf
einstellt andere große amerikanische
konzerne wie beispielsweise mcdonald's
oder coca cola oder pepsi oder starbucks
oder kentucky fried chicken die haben
ihre geschäfte in russland noch nicht
eingestellt und auch da wächst jetzt der
druck herbert wir wollen mal auf
bilderschauen die sehr symbolisch sind
das ist vor gut 30 jahren gewesen da hat
der erste mcdonald's aufgemacht und in
den abendnachrichten wurde groß darüber
berichtet in den usa und wir sehen hier
wie hunderte tausende russen die ersten
filialen gestürmt haben das waren
natürlich auch symbolische bilder die
sowjetunion war zusammengebrochen und
sozusagen der kapitalistischen
klassenfeind hatte die machte dort auf
dem lebensmittelmarkt dann in den in
russland übernommen sehr symbolträchtige
bilder und deshalb hier tombrock oder
damals in den nachrichten der anchorman
berichtete darüber hätte wir haben
vorhin mit peter tiede unserem
korrespondenten in moskau gesprochen er
hat gesagt das würde wirklich wirkung
zeigen werden beispielsweise mcdonald's
dort schließen würde dann würde jeder
große wirklich begreifen was die stunde
geschlagen hatte warum zögert mcdonald's
und pepsi und coca cola und die anderen
ja mcdonald's ist natürlich tatsächlich
eine der berühmtesten amerikanischen
markt erwarten und dass ihr habt da es
gibt acht 140 filialen in russland von
mac damals und die dieser konzern gerät
zu sehen hier in den usa auch in einen
shitstorm genauso wie andere andere
marken wie starbucks oder auch coca cola
ebenfalls berühmte amerikanische markt
marke die firmen haben sich bisher noch
nicht geäußert warum sie ihre filialen
nicht zu sperren wollen in russland es
wird aber erwartet dass dieser druck so
groß wird dass man hier eine änderung
der strategie erwarten kann es gibt
bereits aufrufe auf twitter zum boykott
von coca cola und von mcdonald's auch
hier in den usa das läuft unter dem
hashtag boykott mcdonald's boykott coca
cola hier deutlich dass auch die
konsumenten hier in den usa mobil machen
und druck machen auf diese
firmenzentralen auf diese großen
amerikanischen marken ihre geschäfte in
russland einzustellen im kreuzfeuer der
kritik ist auch starbucks geraten denn
auch starbucks betreibt seine geschäfte
weiter die großen tech konzerne wie
apple oder zum beispiel netflix das
training gegangen haben bereits reagiert
sie haben ihre geschäfte eingestellt in
russland und interessant ist die haltung
von elon musk elon musk ist hier sehr in
erscheinung getreten als verfechter der
ukraine als jemand der keine aktive
licht auch mit seinem satellitensystem
allerdings ist selbst auch hat sich hat
verweigert die tesla fahrzeuge in
russland einfach abschalten zu lassen
das ist ein schritt den er noch nicht
gewagt habe da wird bestimmt noch
einiges passieren vielen dank herr baird
für diese ersten einschätzungen besten
dank nach new york